ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM.
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER BRING IN THE ABSENT
MEMBERS AND THE CLERK WILL CALL
THE ROLL AGUIAR-CURRY ARAMBULA.
OUR QUE HAN BENNETT BERMAN
BIGELOW BLOOM BOERNER HORVATH
BONTA BRIAN CALDERON CARRILLO
CERVANTES GEN JORI COOLEY COOPER
CUNNINGHAM DALLY DAILY DAVIES
FLORA FONG FRIEDMAN GABRIEL
GALLAGHER CRISTINA GARCIA
EDUARDO GARCIA GIPSON GRAY
GRAYSON HOLDEN IRWIN JONES
SAWYER KALRA KILEY BLACKY LEE
LEVINE LOW MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS
MAYES MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN
MURATSUCHI WAS AREA QUINN WELL
DONALD PATTERSON PETRIE-NORRIS
CORK CORK SILVA RAMOS READY IS
THREE OF US ROBERT RIVAS
RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS SANTIAGO
C. R. TO SMITH. STONE TEAM
BALLOT AREAS VIA FOOD LAW VOEPEL
WALDRON MOORED WEBER WICKS. WOOD
MISTER SPEAKER.
WELL.
MEMBERS A
QUORUM IS PRESENT. A QUORUM IS
PRESENT IN THE ASSEMBLY. WE ASK
OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS IN THE
REAR CHAMBER AND IN THE GALLERY
TO PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER.
TODAY'S PRAYER WE OFFERED BY OUR
ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN IMAM YASIR
KHAN IMAM YES SIR. IN THE NAME
OF GOD. THE MOST GRACIOUS THE
MOST MERCIFUL. STRENGTHEN US IN
FAITH WELL LORD. MAYBE HOLD IN
HIGH VALUE THE FACE OF YOUR
PEOPLE. MAY THE LAWS OF THIS
LAND AND THE CONCERNS OF THIS
CHAMBER PROTECT AND NEVER
DIMINISH THE FREE EXERCISE OF
FAITH. MAKE A STEADFAST IN
ADDRESSING DOUBT AND CONFUSION.
GIVE US COMPASSION. SO AS TO
GUIDE THOSE WHO ARE WEAK IN
THEIR CONVICTIONS. FORM OUT OF
US A HAVEN. FOR THOSE WHO LOSE
HOPE BECAUSE OF INJUSTICE. LORD
MAY WE BE CREATIVE AND RESTORING
HOPE. PERSISTENT IN MAKING RIGHT
JUDGMENTS. AND PERSEVERING AND
SPEAKING THE TRUTH. FOR YOU ARE
THE PERFECTOR OF OUR FAITH NOW
AND FOREVER I MEAN. THANK YOU
MOM YES SIR YES OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS TO REMAIN STANDING AND
JOIN US FOR THE FLAG SALUTE.
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GIPSON AS HE LEADS US IN THE
PLEDGE MISTER GIBSON. MEMBERS
RIGHT HEAD OVER OF OVER YOUR
HEART READY BEGIN. ZERO ALL.
THANK YOU MAY BE SEATED. READING
OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL
ASSEMBLY GERMAN SACRAMENTO
WEDNESDAY JANUARY TWENTY SIX
TWENTY TWENTY TO THE ASSEMBLY
BED AT SEVEN AM THE AUDIBLE
SABRINA CERVANTES ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SIXTY TH DISTRICT
RESIDING SHE CLERK SHE PROPER
PEDESTRIAN FOR DAVID BOWMAN
READING ROLL CALL THE FOLLOWING
ARE PLACED UPON THE MORTGAGE
RATE IS MOVES AND MISTER FLORA
SECONDS. THE READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL BE
DISPENSED WITH PRESENTATIONS OF
PETITIONS THERE ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTION REFERENCE OF BILLS
WILL BE DEFERRED. REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ.
AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED SO
JUST FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE ARE
NONE MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE.
THERE ARE NONE MOVIE TO MOTIONS
AND RESOLUTIONS THE ABSENCES FOR
THE DAY WILL BE DEEMED READ. AND
PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL. M. AS
RACE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
PROCEDURAL MOTIONS THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE POINT
FIVE TO ALLOW ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
COOLEY AND BENNETT AND FONG TO
SPEAK ON ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY
TODAY. WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER AND PURSUANT
TO ASSEMBLY ROOM NINETY EIGHT
EVERY QUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
STRIKE THE FOLLOWING VETOED
ITEMS FROM THE FILE. ITEM TO AB
SEVEN RODRIGUEZ ITEM FOR AB FIVE
FIFTEEN CHEN ITEM NINE AB NINE
NINE ZERO SANTIAGO ITEM ELEVEN
AB THIRTEEN THIRTY ONE IRWIN.
AND ITEM THIRTEEN AB EIGHT
SEVENTY TWO WOULD. WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER. THERE IS A LETTER BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LUIS RIVAS AT THE
DESK CONCERNING AB TEN NINE SIX
THREE OF US PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY
RULE FORTY TO SEE A REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO PRINT THE
LETTER IN THE JOURNAL. AGAIN
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER. MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING
TO BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE.
GOVERNOR'S VETOES ITEM SHALL BE
CONTINUED RECONSIDERATION FILE
ITEM SIXTEEN XABI CONTINUE.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO. LLUVIA
TO THE ASSEMBLY. THIRD READING
FILE. BEGINNING WITH FILE ITEM
EIGHTEEN. THIS IS MR MEDINA'S AC
ARE. ONE TWENTY EIGHT. RECOVERY
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
ONE TWENTY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MEDINA RELATIVE TO
NATIONAL SCHOOL COUNSELING WEEK
. MISTER MEDINA MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS TODAY I RISE TO
RECOGNIZE FEBRUARY SEVENTH
THROUGH ELEVEN AS NATIONAL
SCHOOL COUNSELING WEEK. NATIONAL
SCHOOL COUNSELING WEEK
HIGHLIGHTS THE TREMENDOUS IMPACT
THAT SCHOOL COUNSELORS HAVE AND
HELPING STUDENTS ACHIEVE SCHOOL
SUCCESS EMOTIONAL STABILITY AND
PLAN FOR A CAREER. SCHOOL
COUNSELORS DELIVER A RANGE OF
SERVICES TO REDUCE MENTAL HEALTH
STIGMA. IDENTIFY RISK FACTORS
AND WARNING SIGNS OF STUDENTS AT
RISK FOR MENTAL HEALTH AND
BEHAVIORAL DISORDERS. THEY ALSO
PROVIDE COUNSELING SERVICES TO
STRENGTHEN CHILDREN'S PROSPECTS
FOR SCHOOL AND LIFE SUCCESS.
SCHOOL COUNSELORS HAVE BEEN ABLE
TO HELP STUDENTS ADDRESS TRAUMA
CAUSED BY RACIAL. INJUSTICE AND
ARE POSITIONED IN SCHOOL
SETTINGS TO PROMOTE EQUITY
HEALING AND SUPPORT FOR ALL
STUDENTS. THEY ALSO PROVIDE HIGH
QUALITY CAREER EDUCATION TO
PROMOTE THE LINK BETWEEN
LEARNING AND FUTURE CAREER
CHOICES INCLUDING CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION GUIDANCE FOR
A STABLE PATH AFTER GRADUATION.
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL COUNSELORS
DON'T ONLY SUPPORT STUDENTS BUT
THEY ALSO PROVIDE HELP TO
PARENTS TEACHERS AND OTHER
EDUCATORS TO ASSIST YOU IN
EXPLORING THEIR POTENTIAL AND
SET REALISTIC GOALS FOR
THEMSELVES. THE OVER TWELVE
THOUSAND SCHOOL COUNSELORS PLAY
A VITAL ROLE IN THE SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL CAREER AND ACADEMIC
DEVELOPMENT OF OUR CHILDREN AND
WE THANK THEM FOR THEIR WORK. AS
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON ACR ONE
TWENTY EIGHT AND AS THE FIRST
WILL BE OPEN FOR COOPER'S. THANK
YOU MR MEDINA. SEEING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
RESOLUTION MR MEDINA IS ASKING
THAT THE FIRST ROLE THE OPEN FOR
CO AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION THE
CLERK WILL. OPEN THE ROLE. HOW
AUTHORS ON ACR ONE TWENTY EIGHT
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS. THIS IS
FOR CO AUTHORS. CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ALL THERE ARE FIFTY SIX
CO AUTHORS ADDED WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THIS RESOLUTION ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE AYE
OPPOSED SAY NAY. THE EYES HAVE
IT THE RESOLUTION. IS ADOPTED.
WE ARE MOVING TO SENATE THIRD
READING. FILE ITEMS. NINETEEN
THROUGH TWENTY THREE PASS AND
RETAIN. MEMBERS WHERE THE SENATE
THIRD READING FILE WE HAVE A
NUMBER OF BUDGET ITEMS TO TAKE
UP MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO BEGIN
WITH FILE ITEM TWENTY SIX. FILE
ITEM TWENTY SIX. SENATE BILL ONE
FIFTEEN. AND THE CORPORATION
SENATE BILL ONE FIFTEEN BY
SENATOR SKINNER AN ACT RELATING
TO THE STATE BUDGET MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILLS A BILL
. MISTER TAKE YOUR MAIL BUT- BUT
SPEAKER SENATE BILL ONE FIFTEEN
AMENDS THE CURRENT BUDGET- THE
CAR YOUR BUDGET TO ACCOUNT FOR
ADDITIONAL COSTS RELATED FOR
COVERT THE PARTICULARS OF ONE
POINT NINE BILLION DOLLARS
APPROPRIATION TO REFORM
APPROPRIATION FOR COVERT
NINETEEN EXPENSES. WITHIN THAT
IT'S ONE POINT SIX BILLION FOR
PUBLIC HEALTH EXPENSES WHICH
INCLUDES TEXTING. TESTING ARE
NOT NOT NOT TEXTING TESTING ME
TAXING DISTRIBUTION HOSPITAL
COSTS CONTRACT RACING IN OTHER
PUBLIC HEALTH EXPENDITURES- TWO
HUNDRED FIVE POINT FIVE MILLION
FOR CCR EXPENSES OF THE LARGEST
OF WHICH IS GOING TO BE STOPPED
TESTING COSTS. IN A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS FOR ALL WE HAVE
TO EXPENDITURES WHICH INCLUDES
FIFTY MILLION FOR THE
PROCUREMENT OF P. P. ET. AL IT
ALSO CONTAINS A LOAN- TO HELP
STAR STATE AS WELL AS LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. HELP BE BRIDGE
FUNDING FILE FOR RATE RELIEF.
WITH THE HOPE THAT FEDERAL
FUNDING WILL BE COMING SOON IT'S
ALSO THIRTY POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES FOR INCREASED COSTS
FOR. INTERCONNECTION AND
EMISSIONS CONTROL DEVICES- ALSO
ON LASTLY MAKES TECHNICAL
CHANGES TO OF THE STATE TO
CLAIM. THE FEDERAL AMERICAN
RESCUE PLAN ACT FUNDING WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE
VOTE. FOR S. B. ONE ONE FIVE.
THANK YOU MISS TANK AND MR FONG
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. BUT I DID IT
IS ON ALL RIGHT. I THINK ANY
SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE IN
OPPOSITION TO SB ONE FIFTEEN
THIS BILL IS A PATCHWORK OF
CHANGES TO LAST YEAR'S BUDGET
THE FACT THAT THIS IS NOW THE
SIXTH ITERATION ITERATION OF THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT CAN
ONLY MEAN THAT THE BUDGET PASSED
LAST YEAR WAS RUSHED AND NEEDED
TO BE MORE TRANSPARENT. THIS
BILL SPANS NEARLY ANOTHER. TWO
BILLION DOLLARS ON COVERED
RESPONSE WITHOUT PROVIDING
SUFFICIENT JUSTIFICATION.
INCLUDING SEVERAL NO BID
CONTRACTS WITH A NUMBER OF US
HAVE ASK QUESTIONS ABOUT.
MEMBERS THE MEASURE OF SUCCESS
IS NOT DEFINED BY THE AMOUNT OF
MONEY THE STATE SPENDS. IT THERE
MUST BE MEASURABLE OUTCOMES TO
ASSESS THE EFFECTIVENESS. THE
STATE SPENDING OF THE OF THE
STATE SPENDING OF TAXPAYER
MONIES THE GOVERNOR'S AGGRESSION
ON TRADITIONAL ENERGY IS ONCE
AGAIN COSTING TAXPAYERS
MILLIONS. THIS MINUTE
ADMINISTRATION IS DETERMINED TO
KILL SKILLED WELL PAYING JOBS IN
THE ENERGY SECTOR. DESPITE
ATTEMPTS TO FORCE OIL AND
NATURAL GAS OUT OF THE MARKET
CLOSING NUCLEAR POWER PLANTS IN
DEMOLISHING JANET J. DAMS THE
STATE IS BACK TO SQUARE ONE.
LAST YEAR. THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SPENT OVER ONE
HUNDRED SEVENTY MILLION DOLLARS
ON NATURAL GAS GENERATORS TO
MAKE UP FOR A LACK OF ENERGY
SUPPLY. TO PREVENT ROLLING
BLACKOUTS AND NOW. ANOTHER
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS IS NEEDED
TO MEET SELF IMPOSED
REGULATIONS. WE NEED A DIVERSE
ENERGY PORTFOLIO TO MEET THE
RISING ENERGY DEMANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS PICKING WINNERS AND
LOSERS IN THE ENERGY INDUSTRY
CLEARLY IS NOT THE ANSWER TO
SOLVING OUR ENERGY PROBLEMS. THE
BUDGET BILL IS ALSO NO PLACE TO
EXAM TWO CONTRACTS FROM
OVERSIGHT ACCOUNTABILITY REVIEW
AND TRANSPARENCY. THEY CONTRACT
MUST BE DISCLOSED DEBATED AND
ALLOW FOR PUBLIC. INPUT AND
PARTICIPATION. A RUSHED FOR
ABOUT MERE HOURS AFTER
DISCUSSING THIS BILL IN
COMMITTEE IS INAPPROPRIATE THIS
IS NOT HOW THE BUDGET PROCESS
SHOULD WORK. WITH ANOTHER
GENEROUS SURPLUS WE HAVE
ANTICIPATED STATE APPROPRIATION
LIMIT ISSUES AND MANY OF MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE CALLS FOR TAX
RELIEF PERMANENTLY AND REBATES
FOR CALIFORNIANS BUT INSTEAD
THIS BILL PLACE SHOW GAMES WOULD
COVER RESPONSE FUNDS TO GET
AROUND AGAIN LIMIT. CALIFORNIANS
ARE OVERTAXED AND FRUSTRATED
WITH THE GOVERNMENT THAT DOES
NOT LISTEN TO THEM AND FOR THESE
REASONS MEMBERS I ASPIRIN BY
NOVO. SEEING NO OTHER MEMBERS
SEEKING RECOGNITION. ON THE
BUDGET ITEM. CLARK WELL OVER
THERE ALL. DESIRE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE. DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT AYE AYES FIFTY KNOWS FIVE.
THAT MEASURE PASSES. AND WE ARE
GOING TO MOVE TO TAKE UP. FILE
ITEM.
TWENTY FOUR. OKAY MEMBERS
WE ARE GOING TO TAKE A FILE ITEM
TWENTY FOUR. FILE ITEM. TWENTY
FOUR. SENATE BILL ONE THIRTEEN
CORKERY SENATE BILL ONE THIRTEEN
BY THE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND
FISCAL REVIEW WHEN ACCORDING TO
ECONOMIC RELIEF MAKING
APPROPRIATION AIR FORCE TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY PRIVILEGE FOR
THE BUDGET. MISTER CHANG YOUR
MAIL BUT- I THINK IT WAS SPEAKER
LET ME- RIGHT OFF I THINK SB ONE
THIRTEEN IS OUR CORPORATE
NINETEEN ECONOMIC RELIEF BILL.
ALL THE MAJOR ITEM IN THE BILL
IS THE REPEAL OF THE TEMPORARY
LIMIT ON NET OPERATING LOSS
DEDUCTION THE TAX CREDITS ONE
YEAR EARLIER- BY REMOVING THE
LIMITSFOR TWENTY TWENTY TWO LET
ME JUST THANK YOU. MISTER
SPEAKER AS WELLAS OUR COLLEAGUE
FROM ORANGE COUNTY FOR REALLY
ABOUT LEADING THE EFFORT ON THIS
REPEAL IT ALSO CONFORMS STATE
TAX LAW TO FEDERAL LAW FOR THE
RESTAURANT REVITALIZATION FOR
THE START OF VENUES ORGANIZATION
GRANTS. TO EXCLUDE PANDEMIC
RELATED FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE
PROGRAMS FROM STATE TAXABLE
INCOME. FIVE HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION TO THE OFFICE BUSINESS.
FOR SMALL BUSINESS FOR A SMALL
BUSINESS RELIEF GRANT PROGRAM TO
FUND. ALL THOSE BUSINESSES THAT
ON THE WAIT LIST TO APPLIED.
EARLIER LAST YEAR. IT ALSO MAKES
A VARIETY OF CHANGES RELATED TO
A TAX CREDIT PROGRAM THAT'S NOT
GOOD ENOUGH. TWENTY TWENTY ONE
BUDGET AND ENSURE THAT THE
BENEFITS OF UTILITY CUSTOMERS.
RECEIVED A MASTER'S BUDGET ARE
NOT TAXABLE AND EXEMPT FOR
DETERMINING ELIGIBILITY FOR
STATE ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS.
WITHOUT A RESPECT THAT'S PRIVATE
FOR S. B. ONE ONE THREE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN THIS HER
FOGGY ARE RECOGNIZED. I THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER. MEMBERS I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF SB ONE ONE
THREE CALIFORNIA'S EMPLOYERS
HAVE ENDURED TREMENDOUS PRESSURE
IN THE LAST TWO YEARS OF THE
PANDEMIC AND THE THEY NEED ASMUCH RELIEF AS THEY CAN GET.
THIS BILL AS A NEEDED STEP.
MEMBERS CALIFORNIA RANKS ALMOST
DEAD LAST IN BUSINESS TAX
CLIMATE IN THE NATION. RESTORING
THE RESEARCH AND DEVELOPMENT TAX
CREDIT AND NOT NET OPERATING
LOSS DEDUCTIONS IS ONE OF THE
MOST DIRECT WAYS TO HELP
EMPLOYERS SUSTAIN THEIR
BUSINESSES AND HIRE WORKERS.
WITH ANOTHER YEAR OF MULTI
BILLION DOLLAR SURPLUSES. IT
MAKES SENSE TO RESTORE TAX
RELIEF TO RETAIN BUSINESSES IN
OUR STATE. BUT IT IS EVIDENCE
THAT CALIFORNIA OVER TAXES
CALIFORNIANS AND BUSINESSES. THE
STAGE TO CONTINUE TO SUPPORT
EFFORTS TO KEEP BUSINESSES IN
CALIFORNIA WHICH WILL ULTIMATELY
BENEFIT CALIFORNIANS AND THEIR
QUALITY OF LIFE. THIS BILL ALSO
PROVIDES NEEDED CONFORMITY WITH
FEDERAL TAX LAWS SO THAT SMALL
BUSINESSES DO NOT HAVE TO PAY
TAXES ON FEDERAL RELIEF PROVIDED
TO PERSEVERE TO THE PANDEMIC.
AND IT ALSO PROVIDES ADDITIONAL
FUNDING FOR COVERED NINETEEN
RELIEF GRANTS FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES AS WELL. BUT WHAT IS
IMPORTANT TO UNDERSCORE HERE IS
THE NEED FOR MORE TAX RELIEF FOR
CALIFORNIANS AND SMALL
BUSINESSES WHO ARE STRUGGLING TO
LIVE AND WORK IN OUR STATE. I
URGE AND I'VE OUT. THANK YOU
THUS FAR. THIS PETRIE-NORRIS YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
I TO RISE IN STRONG SUPPORT AS
SB ONE ONE THREE AND IN SOME
RESPECTS THIS FEELS LIKE AN
IMPORTANT TURNING POINT IN OUR
BATTLE AGAINST THE KEVIN
NINETEEN PANDEMIC AS OUR BUDGET
CHAIR I'VE SHARED IN HIS OPENING
REMARKS. TWO YEARS AGO AS WE
CONFRONTED THE EARLY STAGES OF
THE COVET NINETEEN PANDEMIC IN
THE SPRING OF TWENTY TWENTY. WE
STOOD ON THE FLOOR AND WE MADE
SOME VERY TOUGH CHOICES I IN
ORDER TO BALANCE OUR STATE'S
BUDGET THAT INCLUDED. THE
TEMPORARY LIMITATION OF NET
OPERATING LOSSES AND TAX CREDITS
FOR CALIFORNIA COMPANIES. WE ARE
MORE THAN TWO YEARS INTOTHIS
PANDEMIC THE TOOL HAS BEEN
DEVASTATING BUT BLESSEDLY WE DO
FIND OURSELVES REALLY AND TRULY
AT A TURNING POINT WE HAVE THE
TREATMENTS OF THE VACCINES THE
TOOLS THAT ARE ENABLING US. TO
MANAGE THE CODE NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. AND WE FIND OURSELVES
BLESSED WITH THE RESOURCES TO
MAKE THE SMART INVESTMENTS WE
NEED TO REBUILD CALIFORNIA AND
SAID OUR ECONOMY ON A ROBUST
PATH TO RECOVERY. THIS ISN'T A
QUESTION OF WHETHER WE
PRIORITIZE PUBLIC HEALTH OR
PRIORITIZE JOB CREATION AND
ECONOMIC GROWTH WE CAN AND MUST
DO BOTH AND THIS MEASURE DOES
JUST THAT SO WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY. URGE AND I BET.
THANK YOU MISS PITCHER NORRIS.
SEEING NO OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION ON THE ITEM. CARCLUB
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE IS
THAT A VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
OUT OF A.
CLARK WELL. CLOSE ROLL
TIDE ABOUT I. SIXTY FOUR NO ZERO
THAT MEASURE PASSES. THIS IS
FILE ITEM. TWENTY FIVE. S. B.
ONE FOURTEEN CORKERY SENATE BILL
ONE FOURTEEN BY THE COMMITTEE ON
BUDGET AND FISCAL REVIEW AN ACT
RELATING TO EMPLOYMENT MAKING
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL OVER TO
THE BUDGET. MISTER CHANG YEAR
MEGAN OPEN. THANK YOU A SPEAKER
S. B. R. ONE FOURTEEN IS OUR
SUPPLEMENTAL PAID SICK LEAVE A
PROPOSAL LAST YEAR AS THE ENTIRE
STATE GRAPPLED WITH COVERT WE
HAD SO MANY EMPLOYEES WHO WENT
TO WORK GET SICK THIS FLOOR
PASSED AND ADOPTED SB NINETY
FIVE WHICH CREATED A COVERT
NINETEEN SUPPLEMENTAL PAID SICK
LEAVE PROPOSAL. HARPER FOR
BUSINESSES WITH MORE THAN TWENTY
FIVE EMPLOYEES UNFORTUNATELY THE
PROPOSAL EXPIRED IN TWENTY FIVE
SORRY IN SEPTEMBER BECAUSE WE
WERE UNABLE TO REACH AGREEMENT
TO EXTEND. THE DAY I'M VERY
PROUD TO PRESENT TO YOU THANKS
IN LARGE PART TO MY COLLEAGUE
FROM LOS ANGELES OUR FABULOUS
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEES ARE
FORTUNATE. SB ONE ONE FOUR WHICH
WILL EXTEND THE PROVISIONS OF SB. CONTINUE TO GO TO WORK
CONTINUE TO GET SICK ACTUALLY
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE
TIME OFF AND GET THE SICK LEAVE
THAT THEY REALLY DESERVE. SB ONE
ONE FOUR APPLIES TO EMPLOYERS
WITH TWENTY SIX OR MORE
EMPLOYEES. AS A FORTY HOUR SICK
LEAVE POLICY ITH AN ADDITIONAL.
FORTY HOURS UNDER CERTAIN STEPS
CERTAIN CIRCUMSTANCES INCLUDES
PROVISIONS SPECIFIC TO BOOSTER
SHOTS AS WELL AS DOCUMENTATION
REQUIREMENTS IN THIS BILL WILL
EXPIRE ON SEPTEMBER THIRTIETH.
OF THIS YEAR TWENTY TWENTY TWO
WITHOUT RESPECT RESTAURANT I
BUILT FOR SB ONE ONE FOUR. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR MISTER FONG YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. I THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER. MEMBERS I AM
FORCING THE RISE IN OPPOSITION
TO SB ONE ONE FOUR THERE ARE
SIGNIFICANT UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES TO THIS BILL
REQUIRING SMALL BUSINESSES AND
NONPROFITS TO PAY UP TO TWO
WEEKS OF SICK PAY LEAVE ON TOP
OF EXISTING PAID LEAVE IS A
FINANCIAL BURDEN THAT COULD
BANKRUPT A LOCAL STORE A LOCAL
RESTAURANT OR A NONPROFIT THAT'S
BARELY HOLDING ON BY THE SKIN OF
THEIR TEETH. THIS MEASURE WILL
NOT ONLY HARM SMALL BUSINESSES
IT WILL HURT NONPROFITS LIKE A
LOCAL HOMELESS CENTER IN KERN
COUNTY WHO SUPPORT OUR
COMMUNITY'S MOST AFFORDABLE
NEIGHBORS AND DID NOT KNOW THE
BUDGET A RETROACTIVE EXPENSE
LIKE THIS IN ONE NOW LOOK TO
REDIRECT FUNDS AT A CRITICAL
TIME. MEMBERS WHY NOT OFFSET
THESE COSTS WITH A STATE TAX
CREDIT OR EXEMPTION THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
PROVIDED ESTIMATES OF FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION TO OVER A
BILLION DOLLARS OF COSTS BORNE
ENTIRELY. BY BUSINESSES AND
NONPROFITS STATEWIDE THERE IS NO
RELIEF PROVIDED FOR THIS AND THE
BILL BEFORE WE DISCUSS PROVIDING
TAX RELIEF AND TRIED TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE FACT THAT
SACRAMENTO IS BURDENING SMALL
BUSINESSES AND THE VERY NEXT
BILL THERE IS A NEED. A MANDATE
ON SMALL BUSINESSES WITH NO
OFFSET AND NO RELIEF PROVIDED.
THIS POLICY THAT IS BEING RUSHED
TO THE LEGISLATURE NEEDED NEEDS
A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT MORE DEBATE
AND DISCUSSION. IT IS
FRUSTRATING BUT AT THE VERY
MOMENT THAT THERE'S SOME
ACKNOWLEDGEMENT OF THE PLIGHT OF
THE CRUSHING COSTS THAT HAVE
BEEN IMPOSED IN OUR COMMUNITIES
BUSINESSES AND CHARITIES THE
PAST TWO YEARS. AND FOR SOME. IT
WAS TOO LATE. AS MANY CLOSE
THEIR DOORS FOR GOOD. THIS
PROPOSAL IS GOING TO LAYER
ADDITIONAL COSTS AND BURDENS ON
TOP OF AN ALREADY DIFFICULT
BUSINESS ENVIRONMENT. MEMBERS I
REGRETFULLY I URGE A NO VOTE.
FAMOUS FONG MISS CARILLO YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. CHECK CHECK OKAY
THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
I RISE TODAY IN SUPPORT OF SB
ONE ONE FOUR WHICH BRINGS BACK
OPEN NINETEENTH OF WOMEN TO SICK
LEAVE FOR EVERY DAY WORKERS
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
WHEN WE ADJOURNED LAST YEAR LAST
SESSION. WE DID SO WITHOUT
CONTEMPLATING THE LIKES OF A NEW
CORONAVIRUS STRAIN LIKE OMICRON
WHICH DISRUPTED THE PROGRESS WE
HAD MADE A BRINGING SOME LEVEL
OF NORMALCY BACK INTO OUR LIVES
NEARLY TWO YEARS INTO THE
PANDEMIC TO PUT THINGS IN
PERSPECTIVE. THE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH STATED JUST LAST MONTH
THAT WE WERE EXPERIENCING THE
HIGHEST CASE NUMBERS EVER
EXCEEDING ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND
CASES ON A DAILY BASIS LOS
ANGELES COUNTY ALONE WHERE MY
DISTRICT IS LOCATED EXCEEDED
MORE THAN TWO MILLION CONFIRMED
CASES IN PART CAUSED BY THE
RAPID SPREAD. OF THE VARIANTS.
JUST LIKE THAT. THE LIVES OF OUR
WORKFORCE WAS UPENDED A MISS
THIS SURGE FORCING MANY TO WORK
SICK OR TO MAKE A CHOICE BETWEEN
LOSING THEIR JOB. OR TAKING CARE
OF THEIR HEALTH OR THE HEALTH OF
A LOVED ONE. THIS IS NOT AN
OPTION THAT PEOPLE SHOULD EVER
HAVE TO MAKE NOT IN CALIFORNIA.
BUT WE WERE FORCED TO DO SO
BECAUSE THE SUPPLEMENTAL PAID
SICK LEAVE LAW WHICH- WE
PREVIOUSLY PASSED HERE IN
CALIFORNIA EXPIRED SEPTEMBER
THIRTY OF LAST YEAR. FOUR
MONTHS. THIS CHOICE ALONE IN THE
LACK OF A SAFETY NET FOR OUR
WORKFORCE MAY HAVE CONTRIBUTED
TO OVER EIGHT MILLION
CALIFORNIANS. TESTING POSITIVE
FOR COVERT NINETEEN AND MORE
THAN EIGHTY THOUSAND LIVES LOST
TO THE VIRUS TO DATE. TODAY'S
VOTE ON THIS BILL IS ONE OF A
SOCIAL AND MORAL CONSCIOUSNESS
BECAUSE COLBERT NINETEEN. IS
TRULY A LIFE OR DEATH ISSUE THAT
WE ARE NOT ONLY AFFECTS THE
HEALTH OF THOSE DIRECTLY
IMPACTED BY IT BUT PEOPLE'S
LIVELIHOODS. AS WELL WHICH IN
TURNS THAT AFFECTS THE HEALTH OF
OUR ECONOMY. HOW MANY OF YOU.
SALT BUSINESSES AND RESTAURANTS
CLOSING THEIR DOORS AGAIN
TEMPORARILY BECAUSE OF THIS
VARIANT. I DARE TO SAY THAT WE
ALL DID. I UNDERSTAND THAT SOME
ORGANIZATIONS ARE REPRESENTING
THESE GROUPS THAT STAND IN
OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL ON
GROUNDS THAT IS DUPLICATIVE OF A
LEAVE REQUIREMENTS THEY
SPECIFICALLY ARGUE THAT
EMPLOYEES EXPOSED TO COVERT
NINETEEN AT WORK OR WHERE OR
WHERE THE EMPLOYER CANNOT.
DISAPPROVE OF AN OCCURRENCE OR
DISAPPROVE OF AN OCCURRENCE ARE
ALREADY ELIGIBLE FOR EXCLUSION
PAY UNDER CAL OSHA'S COVERT
NINETEEN EMERGENCY TEMPORARY
STANDARD OR THAT EMPLOYERS
PROVIDE SUPPLEMENTAL LEAVE
BENEFITS BENEFITS OF THEIR OWN
AS WELL. WHAT THEY FAIL TO
ACKNOWLEDGE HOWEVER IS THE
WORKER WHO DOES NOT CONTRACT THE
VIRUS AT WORK WHO DOES NOT HAVE
AN EMPLOYER THAT PROVIDES IN THE
BENEFIT OR THE NEEDS TO CARE FOR
A FAMILY MEMBER. OR A CHILD WHO
HAS FALLEN ILL BECAUSE OF CODE
WHICH IN ALL CASES FORCES THEM
TO WORK SICK OR LOSE THEIR JOB
AS STATED EARLIER. HAVING SAID
THIS WE ARE NOT OBLIVIOUS TO THE
STRUGGLES OF BUSINESS COMMUNITY
DURING THIS PANDEMIC ESPECIALLY
OUR SMALL BUSINESSES FOR THIS
REASON WE ARE NOT ONLY TAKING
ACTIONS TODAY THAT PROVIDE
SUPPORT FOR BUSINESSES IN THE
FORM OF SOME TAX CREDITS BUT WE
ARE COMMITTED TO ADDRESSING THE
ADDITIONAL NEEDS OF SMALL
BUSINESSES BECAUSE THAT'S STATED
BY THE GOVERNOR BY THE PRO TEM
AND ARE ASSEMBLY SPEAKER. SMALL
BUSINESSES ARE THE BACKBONE OF
OUR COMMUNITIES AND CONTINUE TO
BE IMPACTED BY COVERT NINETEEN.
IF THERE IS ONE LESSON. WE HAVE
LEARNED FROM LAST YEAR'S ACTION
ON SUPPLEMENTAL SICK LEAVE. IS
THAT WE DID IT IT WORKED AND WE
CAN DO IT AGAIN. TODAY'S EARLY
BUDGET ACTIONS ARE RIGHT FOR
WORKERS BUSINESSES AND OUR
ECONOMY THESE ISSUES ARE NOT
MUTUALLY EXCLUSIVE WE CAN DO ALL
OF IT. THE BIGGEST UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCE TO DOING NTHING. IS
CONTINUING THE LOSS OF LIFE
ACROSS OUR STATE. MEMBERS LET'S
CONTINUE TO HELP THE FORTY
MILLION PEOPLE THAT CALL
CALIFORNIA HOME AMID THIS
PANDEMIC AND I RESPECTFULLY URGE
AND I VOTE ON SB ONE ONE FOUR
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MS CREO.
SEEING NO OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION ON THE ITEM. MISTER
CHANG YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU
FOR SPEAK APPRECIATE MY CALL
WHICH OF COMMENTS FROM OUR VICE
CHAIR AS WELL AS FROM MY
COLLEAGUE FROM THE SAN ANGELES
SB ONE ONE FORCE A MEASURE
THAT'S ACTUALLY CRITICAL TO
ENSURE THAT WE SUPPORT ALL THE
WORKERS WITH KEPT OUR ECONOMY
OPEN. UP A RESTAURANT OPEN
COOPER SMALL BUSINESSES OPEN
REALLY COMMITTED SO THAT WE CAN
GET THROUGH THE WEEK TO CONTINUE
TO GO ON WITH OUR LIVES AND THEY
PUT THEIR LIVES AT RISK BUT THE
LIVELIHOOD TO REST SO I THINK
THE COVERT SICK LEAVE IS THE
LEAST WE CAN DO. HAVING SAID
THAT HIGH I DO A ONE ALLIANCE
MYSELF WITH SOME OF THE COMMENTS
MY FRAZIER MADE TO ENSURE THAT
THE SMALL BUSINESSES WHO
DEFINITELY NEED FINANCIAL LEAVE
GET THAT RELIEF WE WERE NOT ABLE
TO GET THAT THE TO THIS PROPOSAL
BUT SOMETHING THAT WE CONTINUE
TO. TALK ABOUT WE REALLY WOULD
LOVE TO SEE THAT IN THE JUNE
BUDGET PROPOSAL BECAUSE I THINK
IT'S ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL THAT
BECAUSE THE FEDERAL AID IS NOT
THERE THAT STATE AID WORK TO
HELP THE SMALL BUSINESSES WHO
ARE HAVING TO BEAR SOME OF HIS
BRENT FOR CALL THE SICKLY.
WITHOUT A RESPECTFULLY ASK FIVE
VOTE ON S. B. ONE ONE FOUR.
THANK STAYING AT WITH THAT CLARK
WILL OPEN THE RAW. SARAH VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED SARAH VOTE.
CLARK WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT ICE FIFTY FIVE NO SEVEN
THAT MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS WE
ARE FILE ITEM TWENTY SEVEN. S.
B. ONE SIXTEEN. CORKERY SENATE
BILL ONE SIXTEEN BY THE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND FISCAL
REVIEW IMMACULATE INTOHUMAN
SERVICES MAKING APPROPRIATION
THEREFORE TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY BUT RATHER TO THE
BUDGET. MISTER CHANG YOU MAKE AN
OPEN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER SB ONE ONE SIX IS OUR
HUMAN SERVICES EARLY ACTION
TRAILER BILL MODIFIES TWO MAJOR
COMPONENTS ONE IS A CREATES
FLEXIBILITY IN THE USE OF
FEDERAL FUNDS FOR OUR STATE AS
WE RECEIVE THEM FOR REFUGEE
RESETTLEMENT CURRENTLY OUR
COUNTY AND OUR NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS ARE THE MAIN
PROVIDERS OF SERVICES. FOR
REFUGEES IN PARTICULAR FROM
AFGHANISTAN OF WHAT WE'RE ASKING
IS TO GIVE LOCAL JURISDICTIONS A
LITTLE BIT MORE FLEXIBILITY THAT
IN CASE A COUNTY OR NONPROFIT
PROVIDER CANNOT BE IDENTIFIED TO
PROVIDE THOSE SERVICES THAT WE
CAN HAVE A SMALL WINDOW OF TIME
FROM NOW UNTIL DECEMBER THIRTY
FIRST OF THIS YEAR. TO OUR
CONTRACT WITH A PRIVATE ENTITIES
LASTLY THE LANGUAGE INCLUDES
REPORTING REQUIREMENT TO THE
LEGISLATURE TO ENSURE THAT THE
MONEY HAS ACHIEVED OUTCOMES.
WHICH WE ARE WHICH TO SEE
HAPPEN. SECONDLY IT INCLUDES
TWENTY SEVEN MILLION DOLLAR
PROPOSITION IN CHILD CARE SPACE
TO COVER ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS.
FOR THE PROVIDING FOR THE
PROVISION OF REIMBURSEMENT
RESETTLEMENTS TO FAMILY CHILD
CARE PROVIDERS. ALSO HAS A
NUMBER OF CHOPPING OUT ISSUES
WITHOUT A RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AYE VOTE ON SB ONE ONE SIX.
THANK WHICH TAKE MR FONG YOUR
RECOGNIZE. I THANK MR SPEAKER
MEMBERS I RISE IN SUPPORT OF SB
ONE ONE SIX HIS BILL
APPROPRIATES FUNDS TO SUPPORT A
FAMILY CHILD CARE PROVIDERS IT
ALSO ENSURES THAT FEDERAL FUNDS
AVAILABLE TO SUPPORT EFFORTS TO
ASSIST AFGHAN REFUGEE FAMILIES
THAT FLED THEIR WAR TORN COUNTRY
TO COME TO CALIFORNIA. AYE
ORIGIN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISS
FONG. SAY NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE ITEM CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. PAUL MEMBERS
VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE. CLARK WELL
CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF I. SIXTY
EIGHT NO ZERO. THAT MEASURE
PASSES AND FINALLY THIS IS FILE
ITEM TWENTY EIGHT. SB ONE
SEVENTEEN CORPORATION. SENATE
BILL ONE SEVENTEEN BY THE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND FISCAL
REVIEW AN APPALACHIAN STATE
EMPLOYMENT MAKING APPROPRIATION
THEREFORE TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY BUT RATHER TO THE
BUDGET MR KING EMAIL. THANK YOU
MUCH MISTER SPEAKER SB ONE ONE
SEVEN AMEND SIX MO USE. THE
PARTICULAR RELATING TO
COMPENSATION REGARDING TELEWORK-
THE SIX BARGAINING UNITS ARE
REACHED AGREEMENT WITH THE
STATE. TO ALSO RECEIVE A MONTHLY
STIPEND FOR TELEWORK COST THE
TOTAL AGREEMENT WILL COST
APPROXIMATELY TWENTY SEVEN
MILLION EIGHT MILLION OF WHICH
IS GENERAL FUND. OF EXPECTED
COSTS A WITHOUT A RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR I BUILT ON SB ONE ONE
SEVEN. A MEASURE FALL. I THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF SB ONE ONE SEVEN THIS
BILL APPROVED IN FUNDS
AGREEMENTS NEGOTIATED BETWEEN
THE DEPARTMENT OF HUMAN
RESOURCES AND SIX STATE
BARGAINING UNITS. HIRES I'VE OF. THANK YOU THIS FALL C.
NOTIFICATION OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM. CORPORAL. ZERO ALL MEMBERS
FROM THE DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT I. SIXTY SIX NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES. AND WITHOUT
OBJECTION MISTER TANK REQUEST
THE MEDIA TRANSMITTAL OF THOSE
BUDGET ITEMS TO THE SENATE.
MEMBERS WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED.
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY MEMBERS I
WOULD ASK THAT YOU PLEASE TAKE
YOUR SEATS. PLEASE TAKE YOUR
SEATS AT THIS TIME QUORUM CALL
REMAINS IN PLACE. PLEASE TAKE
ANY CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE
FLOOR. PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
MEMBERS OR TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE FLOOR
AT THIS TIME.
MEMBERS WHERE THE
GERMANS IN MEMORY I ASK THAT YOU
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS AT THIS
TIME. AND TAKE ANY CONVERSATIONS
. OFF OF THE FLOOR.
THE
FOLLOWING MEMBERS WERE GRANTED
PERMISSION TO SPEAK ON A GERMAN
IN MEMORY. MR COOLEY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED AT YOUR DESK YOUR
GERMAN IN MEMORY. COLLEAGUES IT
IS A GREAT HONOR TODAY TO STAND
AND- HONOR IN MEMORY A MEMBER OF
THIS HOUSE THE STATE SENATE. AND
AS I DO SO YOU WILL LEARN
SOMETHING ABOUT THIS NOTABLE
INDIVIDUALS CAREER. BUT I FEEL A
CERTAIN KINSHIP TO THEM. YOU
WILL HEAR THAT JOHN F. KENNEDY
AND HIS PULITZER PRIZE WINNING
BOOK PROFILES IN COURAGE. PLAYED
A BIG ROLE IN MOTIVATING HIM IN
HIS LIFE. AND I REMEMBER READING
THAT AS A YOUNG PERSON. AND SO
IS THE RESIDENT HISTORIAN I WILL
KNOW FOR YOU ALL. THAT THAT YEAR
THE JOHN F. KENNEDY BECAME
PRESIDENT. THIS INDIVIDUAL WHO
CARVED OUT A PLACE. OF
DISTINCTION AND EDUCATION
CALIFORNIA. IT EASIER JOHN OKAY
BECAME PRESIDENT WE ESTABLISHED
ONE CSU. CSU ROHNERT PARK- SO
NORMAL CAL STATE CINEMA. AND IF
THE MODEL IS LACKS LOCKS MENTORS
. LUXOR BUS NIGHT OF THE MIND.
LIGHT OF THE WORLD. I THINK THAT
REFLECTS UPON THE TEMPER OF THE
TIMES YOU EXCITEMENT PEOPLE FELT
THE VISION. OF THE NATURE OF OUR
DEMOCRACY. LIED OF THE MIND
LIGHT OF THE WORLD AND I THINK
IT I ONLY ADVOCATE BECAUSE IT'S
VERY APPROPRIATE TO THIS
INDIVIDUAL I TURN TO NOW FROM
JFK WAS A VERY IMPORTANT PERSON
IN NINETEEN SIXTY SIXTY ONE A
VERY IMPORTANT YEAR. FOR US ALL
. FIFTY CURRENT MEMBERS ARE RISE
TODAY TO ADJOURN. IN MEMORY OF
FORMER STATE LAWMAKER GARY HART
. BELOVED AS AN EDUCATOR AND FOR
HIS COMMITMENT TO EDUCATION.
KERREY SERVED IN THIS HOUSE AND
THE STATE SENATE. AND HIS
EDUCATION SECRETARY TO GOVERNOR
GRAY DAVIS. I DO CENTER HEART IS
MY CONSTITUENT. FOR HE SOUGHT ME
OUT. EARLY IN MY ASSEMBLY CAREER%
. TO SUPPORT ME AND MY WORK. I
DEEPLY REGRET CENTER HEART
PASSED AWAY ON JANUARY TWENTY
SEVENTH OF THIS YOUNG YEAR.
AFTER A HARD FOUGHT BATTLE
AGAINST PANCREATIC CANCER.
SENATOR GARY HART WAS SEVENTY
EIGHT. GARY WAS BORN DURING
WORLD WAR TWO. AND WAS RAISED BY
HIS MOM IN SAN DIEGO. UNTIL HIS
DAD RETURNED FROM SERVICE IN THE
PACIFIC THEATER. BY THEN YOUNG
GARY WAS A THREE YEAR OLD. WHEN
I GOT TO SEE HIS DAD AGAIN. AT
AN EARLY AGE HARPER WAS
INTRIGUED BY POLITICS AND PUBLIC
SERVICE. HE BECAME EIGHTEEN TURN
THIRTEEN SHORTLY AFTER JFK'S
BOOK PROFILES IN COURAGE WAS
PUBLISHED IN NINETEEN FIFTY SIX
. THAT BOOK ABOUT EIGHT US
SENATORS WHOSE COURAGEOUS STAND
SHAPED OUR NATION. INSPIRED HERE
TO BECOME PRESIDENT NOT JUST OF
HIS JUNIOR HIGH SCHOOL BUT OF
HIS SENIOR HIGH SCHOOL. SO YOU
KNOW THE POSSIBILITY OF RUNNING
FOR OFFICE CAPTURED HIS
IMAGINATION EARLY. IN ACADEMICS
GEHRY WAS A GIFTED ATHLETE. WHO
WENT TO STANFORD. ON A FOOTBALL
SCHOLARSHIP. HE COMPLETED A
DEGREE IN HISTORY THERE. AND
THEN WENT ON TO EARN A MASTERS
IN TEACHING AT HARVARD'S
GRADUATE SCHOOL OF EDUCATION.
JERRY WAS A LIFELONG EDUCATOR HE
TAUGHT HIGH SCHOOL SOCIAL
STUDIES CLASSES IN SANTA BARBARA
. AND LATER HERE IN SACRAMENTO
COUNTY AT KENNEDY HIGH SCHOOL.
AND WHILE IT CAN BE GEHRY
FOUNDED OF THE HONORS AND HE
MANAGED PROGRAM PACE. WHICH HAS
NOW HAD MORE THAN TWO THOUSAND
GRADUATES SINCE IT GOT GOING IN
TWO THOUSAND THREE. GERRY'S
COMMITMENT TO PUBLIC EDUCATION
DEMOCRACY WAS HEARTFELT. AND
LIFELONG. SENATOR GARY HART
HEADED DEEP SEATED CONVICTION
THAT I KNOW MANY SHARON HERE ON
THIS FLOOR. THAT EDUCATION AND
STUDENT DIVERSITY. WHERE THE
FOUNDATIONS FOR A HEALTHY
DEMOCRACY. SENATOR HART'S
PROGRESSIVE VIEWS WOULD NEED HIM
TO AN INFLUENTIAL POLITICAL
CAREER WHICH BEGAN IN NINETEEN
SIXTY SEVEN. THAT YEAR GARY HART
WORKED ON SHIFTS SENATOR EUGENE
MCCARTHY'S PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN
. AS WELL AS ALL LOANS TIMES
CONGRESSIONAL CAMPAIGN. IT WAS
DURING HIS TIME WORKING ON THESE
CAMPAIGNS. WHICH I ASSURE YOU
ONE PERSON IN THIS ROOM.
REMEMBERS WHAT THE GREATEST
TENDERNESS. IT WAS WHILE WORKING
ON THESE CAMPAIGNS HE MET THE
LOVE OF HIS LIFE KERRY SMITH.
WHEN THEY MET KERRY WAS A
COLLEGE STUDENT. AND WE CAN
CAMPAIGN VOLUNTEER. AND THEY
MARRIED ONE YEAR LATER. IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR GEHRY WAS
ELECTED SANTA BARBARA COUNTY'S
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. THEN IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO HE MADE THE
JUMP TO THE STATE SENATE.
REPRESENT A COASTAL SANTA
BARBARA VENTURA AND LOS ANGELES
COUNTIES. HE SERVED IN THE
SENATE UNTIL NINETEEN NINETY
FOUR. AS A LAWMAKER GARY HART
WAS A TRAILBLAZER IN OFFERING
MAJOR LEGISLATION. ESPECIALLY IN
THE FIELDS OF EDUCATION. THE
ENVIRONMENT AND WOMEN'S RIGHTS.
HE WORKED STEADILY TO INCREASE
FOR SCHOOL FUNDING AND DECREASE
CLASS SIZES. GARY AUTHORED BILLS
TO STRENGTHEN CHILD CARE AND
CHILD SUPPORT IN CALIFORNIA. HIS
INTEREST IN THE ENVIRONMENT LED
TO PROTECTIONS FOR THE COAST AND
FOR WILDLIFE. AND GARY HART
SERVED AND EARLY VERSION OF
CALIFORNIA'S COASTAL COMMISSION
. AND STUDIES HE INITIATED
LETTER THE COURSE OF TIME TO THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF CSU CHANNEL
ISLANDS SERVING THE COAST WHERE
HE GREW UP. IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
THREE THE LEGISLATURE PASSED ONE
OF GARY SIGNATURE PIECE OF
LEGISLATION. THE HUGE HEART
EDUCATION REFORM ACT THAT
ACCORDING TO RECENT NEWS.
COMPLETE WITH THE FUNDING
NECESSARY TO COVER ITS EIGHT
HUNDRED MILLION PROGRAM COSTS.
UPON LEAVING THE STATE SENATE
NINETEEN NINETY FIVE GEHRY
FOUNDED THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY INSTITUTE FOR
EDUCATION REFORM. A POLICY
CENTER FOCUS BEING ON ELEMENTARY
AND SECONDARY SCHOOL ISSUES.
SENATOR HART WAS PROUD TO
RECEIVE THE HIGHEST RANKINGS IN
INTEGRITY FOR THE CALIFORNIA
JOURNAL SURVEY OF LEGISLATORS
STAFFERS AND LOBBYISTS. HE WAS
ALSO RECOGNIZED BY COMMON CALLS
FOR HIS TWENTY YEARS OF
PRINCIPLED LEGISLATIVE
LEADERSHIP. OUR COMMUNITY HERE
SECOND ACCOUNTABLE TO DO THE
WHOLE STATE WILL FOREVER
REMEMBER CALIFORNIA IS IMMINENT
GARY HART. HE IS SURVIVED TODAY
BY HIS WIFE CAREY HART. WHO IS
PRESENT WITH US TODAY IN THE
GALLERY. HE HAS THREE DAUGHTERS
ALYSSA HART MAY HAN CATHERINE
HART AND LAURA MARIE. AND SIX
GRANDCHILDREN LANE AND ELEANOR
MAY HAND NORA AND CLARA TO WIRE
AND JACK AND HANK MURRAY. MRS
HART IS JOINED THE CHAMBERS
GALLERY BY LONGTIME STAFF MEMBER
PHYLLIS CHILD. AS WELL I BELIEVE
LIST IN N. OUT OR PRESENT ABOVE
THAT I MISSED OTHER STAFF TO
CENTER HARD TO SHARE IN THE
FAMILY'S LOSS. AND ASHLEY JR AND
TODAY AND SENATOR GARY HART'S
MEMORY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISS COOLEY. MISTER BENNETT YOU
TWO ARE RECOGNIZED ON THE STREET
GERMAN IN MEMORY FROM IS RACES
DESK. MISTER BENNETT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER SPEAKER- I JOIN
MY COLLEAGUE FROM RANCHO
CORDOVA- IN REQUESTING THAT THIS
ASSEMBLY ADJOURNED IN MEMORY OF
A TRULY REMARKABLE MAN. MISTER
JERRY CAPEHART. HE SERVED-
RESIDENTS THE CONSTITUENTS OF
SANTA BARBARA VENTURA COUNTY
WHICH REAL DISTINCTION HE WAS
SOMEBODY THAT VIRTUALLY
EVERYBODY ADMIRED ON BOTH SIDES
OF THE- HE SERVED WITH INTEGRITY
AND MOST IMPORTANTLY HE REALLY
SERVICE PRINCIPLE YOU KNEW WHAT
HE STOOD FOR- AND THEY HAD THE
COURAGE TO STAND UP FOR HIS
CONVICTION. I WAS A BUSY. HIGH
SCHOOL TEACHER AND COACH AND NOT
AT ALL INVOLVED IN POLITICS AND
LOCAL POLITICS. UNTIL K. HART
DECIDED TO RUN FOR CONGRESS. AND
THE SHOW INSPIRED ME AS I A
CARVED OUT TIME AND WORK. AND HE
CAME WITHIN ONE PERCENTAGE POINT
OF DEFEATING. THE INCUMBENT WHO
HAD BEEN SERVING FOR A LONG
TIME- IN CONGRESS. BUT HE WAS
ABLE TO MOTIVATE SO MANY YOUNG
PEOPLE. AND HIS CONTRIBUTIONS AS
HAS BEEN ELOQUENTLY IDENTIFIED A
WILL STAND FOR A LONG TIME AND
THE EDUCATION WORLD IN
CALIFORNIA. SO- MMHM I WAS
SADDENED TO HEAR OF HIS LOSS
WHEN ONE OF HIS GOOD FRIENDS-
TIM HURT- CONTACTED ME. LOCAL
NEWSPAPER REPORTER DOWN VENTURA
COUNTY WHO NOW LIVES UP HERE AND
WAS FRIENDS WITH THE HART
FAMILY- BUT I AM ENCOURAGED BY
THE FACT THAT- HIS LEGACY IS
GOING TO LIVE ON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE INSTITUTE. FOR
EDUCATION REFORM AND THAT IS
LEGACY'S GOING TO LIVE ON
BECAUSE I CAN'T IMAGINE THAT A
MAN AS REMARKABLE AS HIM AS NOT-
RAISED THREE REMARKABLE CHILDREN
AND HELPED RAISE SIX REMARKABLE
GRANDCHILDREN SO TO CARRY ON THE
FAMILY I HOPE YOU'LL ALL JOIN ME
IN WISHING THEM WELL AS IF. THIS
A TRAGIC LOSS OF THE KERRY CARE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
MISTER BENNETT. THANK YOU
MEMBERS WE DO HAVE AN ADDITIONAL
THE GERMAN IN MEMORY. WE WILL
LIFT THE QUORUM CALL AT THIS
TIME I WOULD ASK THAT YOU PLEASE
. TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF OF
THE FLOOR WE DO HAVE AN
ADDITIONAL ADJOURNMENT IN THE
MEMORY.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR
ONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE FLOOR
AT THIS TIME. OR TAKE YOUR SEATS.
AND MR FONG YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR GERMAN IN MEMORY. I
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER. A
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO ASK THAT
THE ASSEMBLY ADJOURNED IN THE
MEMORY OF MY EMAIL TIA A
CULTURAL AND CULINARY ICON IT
EMIGRATED FROM THE BASQUE REGION
OF FRANCE WHICH WAS JUST
SEVENTEEN YEARS OLD AND BROUGHT
WITH HER STRONG VALUES OF THE
IMPORTANCEOF CARING FOR OTHERS.
HOW TO GIVE AND HOW TO SHARE
WHILE WORKING AT RESTAURANTS IN
BAKERSFIELD MY EMAIL HER HUSBAND
JB AND THEY SOON WELCOME THEIR
CHILDREN JENNY AND DANIEL. JUST
A COUPLE WEEKS AFTER THEIR SON
WAS BORN MY IAN HER HUSBAND
OPENED THEIR OWN RESTAURANT THE
FAMOUS WILL GO OVER HIS
RESTAURANT IN BAKERSFIELD
CALIFORNIA FULL OF AMBITION AND
A PASSION FOR SHARING MY E. AND
J. B. THAT WILL GROWERS TO
DECADES OF SUCCESS WITH THEIR
DELICIOUS HEARTY MEALS AND WARM
FAMILY SPIRIT. BUT MY HE WAS
ALSO INCREDIBLY DEDICATED TO
WALKING WELCOMING BASQUE
IMMIGRANTS IN NEED A SHE HAD
EXPERIENCED MOVING TO A NEW
COUNTRY IS AN INCREDIBLE FEAT SO
SHE DEDICATED HER TIME AND
RESOURCES TO HELP NEW IMMIGRANTS
WITH ADJUSTING TO LIFE IN THE
UNITED STATES. SHE WOULD EVEN
TAKE THEM TO THE DMV CONSULATE-
DOCTORS APPOINTMENTS HER
GENEROSITY WAS TRUE AND
LIMITLESS CONSTANTLY DEDICATING
HERSELF TO OTHERS IN SUPPORTING
HER LOVING FAMILY. MY YOU PASSED
AWAY ON DECEMBER FIFTEENTH. AT
THE AGE OF NINETY TWO. HER
DAUGHTER AND GRANDDAUGHTER.
CARRY ON HER DREAM AND LEGACY
OPERATING A RESTAURANT AND I
ASKED THAT THE ASSEMBLY
ADJOURNED IN MY EASE MEMORY
TODAY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISS
FONG THANK YOU MEMBERS PLEASE
BRING THE NAMES TO THE DESK TO
BE PRINT IN THE JOURNAL. ALL
REQUESTS RICHARD A MEMORIES WILL
BE DEEMED READ. AND PRINTED IN
THE JOURNAL. THERE ARE TWO
BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE MEETINGS
TODAY. BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE ONE
ON HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
WILL MEET. AT TWO THIRTY IN ROOM
FOR FORTY SEVEN. BUDGET SUB
COMMITTEE FIVE ON PUBLIC SAFETY
WILL MEET AT TWO THIRTY IN ROOM. FOUR THIRTY SEVEN. WHEN YOU
SEE MISTER CHANG PLEASE WISH HIM
A HAPPY BIRTHDAY HIS BIRTHDAY
WILL BE THIS WEDNESDAY. SESSION
SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS TUESDAY
FEBRUARY SECOND SESSION
WEDNESDAY FEBRUARY NINTH ALSO
CHECK IN SESSION THURSDAY
FEBRUARY TENTH. THE FLOOR
SESSION IS AT NINE AM ALL OF THE
ITEMS REMAINING WILL BE PASSED
RETAIN ALL MOTION SHALL BE
CONTINUED. SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER BUSINESS I'M READY TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO ADJOURN IS
BOTTOM MOVES. AND MS DR CORK
SECONDS THAT THIS HOUSE STANDS
ADJOURNED UNTIL THURSDAY
FEBRUARY THE TENTH. AT NINE AM
WE ARE DURING.